this is Conan O'Brien's mm all right
well in the NFC I'm picking the San
Francisco 49ers wait aren't they
supposed to be terrible this year not
according to my research I say five-time
Pro Bowl quarterback Joe Montana and his
go to wide receiver Jerry Rice will lead
the Niners back to the Super Bowl where
they belong
in the AFC I like the Denver Broncos
behind their own strong arm quarterback
John Elway can I see a great future for
that kid Conan he's retired also look
for solid rookie seasons from the Lions
Barry Sanders and the Cowboys Troy
Aikman all leading to a classic Super
Bowl in New Orleans where the halftime
show will feature a clarinetist Pete
fountain and a tribute to the comic
strip Peanuts it's gonna be a great year
[Applause]
please where do you get your sports
information we talk about the 1989
Sports Illustrated NFL preview is June
Oh Conan were you at the dentist's
office today yeah
that's where I get all my sports news
and your dentist made a fool of you
doctors and dentists for the love of God
please refresh the reading material in
your offices on a regular basis don't
let an old issue hey Andy it says here
the compact disc is gonna make cassette
tapes obsolete become a serious issue
it's gonna oh wait a second wait a
second and you people love reading old
magazines it's a fun guilty pleasure
doctors and dentists please when it
comes to old magazines
don't lose your patience where you lose
your patience it's medical offices throw
away those old copies copy
[Music]
now doctors let the magazine's be old or
your practice will fold thinking come on
Doc let the magazines gather dust if you
want your practice to go bust don't let
a sidekick kick your practice to the
side wait kick your practice to the side
that's really lame lame Andy now there's
something we can both agree on
[Laughter]
you
you